[Musique]
si c'est le plus grand empire de tous
les temps
il ne s'est pas bâtie en un jour
grandeur à la décadence
[Musique]
puis rentrer
à la couture
en
[Musique]
bonjour je suis joe mantegna à la fin du
1er siècle après jésus-christ les
frontières de l'empiré romain englobe la
majeure partie des pays pratiquant les
échanges commerciaux le peuple romain
est devenu un véritable creuset ethnique
des cultures très diverses en provenance
de jérusalem d'athènes ou de pompéi se
rencontrent et se mélangent
malgré leurs différences ces individus
ont un point commun la construction des
fondations d'un seul et même en pire
celle ci se fera à travers de
prodigieuses réalisations telles que des
temples des aqueducs des ponts des
routes
je vous invite à suivre la construction
d'un empire
[Musique]
l' empire romain est devenue un immense
melting-pot culturel une nation offrant
une incroyable variété d'image de son et
d'odeurs en 80 après jésus-christ le
sentiment d'une citoyenneté romaine a
fait son chemin à travers l'ensemble du
monde méditerranéen lempire c'est en
effet de la grande-bretagne à la syrie
en passant par une kyrielle de
territoire de la côte atlantique du
portugal et des montagnes d'europe
centrale jusqu'au désert d'égypte et
bien au delà du moyen-orient
rome fait toujours figure de capitale du
monde c'est une ville très cosmopolite
mais à la fin du 1er siècle après
jésus-christ quatre mille autres roms
sont apparus à travers les provinces de
l'empiré romain jusqu'au 3ème siècle la
puissance et l'ingéniosité du
gouvernement et de son armée permettent
la vaste politique expansionniste que
l'on connaît des légions fortement
armées participent à la construction des
fondations de cette superpuissance
méditerranéenne en conquérant de
nombreux territoires étrangers
lorsque les romains s'empare d'une
région il commence par y envoyer un
groupe de juristes chargée d'étudier la
possibilité d'unifier la législation
locale avec les lois romaines l'empereur
nomme ensuite un gouverneur romain à la
tête de chacune de ces nouvelles
provinces
à leur tour les provinces élisent leurs
conseils municipaux qui procéderont aux
décisions locales
[Musique]
je me souviens que la première fois que
je me suis rendu dans la capitale afin
d'effectuer des recherches sur la rome
antique
je me suis sentie submergée par la ville
très lentement j'ai commencé à vouloir
sortir de rome pour explorer les limites
de l' empire est partout je me suis
rendu ensuite en afrique du nord en
grèce en turquie au moyen-orient en
syrie j'ai trouvé des traces physiques
du passage des romains on reconnaît dans
chacun de ces lieux
la trace de l'unification de l' empire
ne serait ce que par les vestiges
architecturaux men qu'on y trouve
on autorise malgré tout la plupart de
ces territoires romain à garder leur
identité propre c'est ainsi qu'ils
continuent d'apporter chacun à l' empire
leur lot de spécificités en syrie la
ville de palmyre joue le rôle de lien
essentiel dans les échanges commerciaux
entre europe de l'ouest et en asie
c'est par elle que transitent les épices
et là soient acheminés vers rome
dans ce qui préfigure la turquie
actuelle l'ancienne ville d'affreux
d'isis abrite la plus prestigieuse école
de sculpture de l' empire
[Musique]
loin de là à baffes en angleterre les
sources thermales et établissements de
bains devienne un lieu de cure
thérapeutique prisé par les aristocrates
de la haute société
désireux de se refaire une santé
à peu larchitecture commence à mêler les
styles romain et locales si les grandes
villes de ses nombreuses provinces
incarne bien l'aspect public de lempire
d'autres symbolise davantage les détails
de la vie privée des romains c'est le
cas à 240 km au sud de rome de la ville
de pompéi
niché au pied du vésuve dans la baie de
naples pompéi devient l'un des lieux de
villégiature de la haute société romaine
pendant que quelques étrangers s'y
prélassent au soleil dans la douceur de
ses brise parfumer la population y mène
une vie trépidante et prospère si l'on
pouvait se projeter en arrière dans
l'antiquité
je crois qu'on serait d'abord très
frappé par l'absence de voitures de
klaxons et de fumées d'échappement
par contre on verrait des chariots tirés
par des chevaux
on entendrait le grincement épouvantable
que faisait les roues sur le pavé on
sentirait des odeurs auquel on ne
s'attend pas par exemple l'auteur de l'
urine dans laquelle on lavait le linge
ou le parfum des épices exotiques
émanant des épiceries
à pompéi on flâne volontiers le long de
trottoirs étroits ont fait du lèche
vitrine il y a là des tissus de la
nourriture les gens font longuement la
queue devant les boulangeries
comme devant ce four pour acheter une
miche de pain ou encore des biscuits
spéciaux pour les chiens les citoyens
peuvent aussi s'arrêter prendre un
casse-croûte auprès de l'une des très
nombreuses échoppes proposant des plats
à emporter
beaucoup de gens modestes ne possédant
pas de cuisine se nourrissent d'ailleurs
de cette manière voici le meilleur
exemple de ses comptoirs que l'on
trouvait en abondance dans les rues de
pompéi et qui était percé de trous les
archéologues italiens les appels des
thermopyles haye
ce qui signifie littéralement magasin à
repas chaud fort heureusement la
nourriture ne se prêtait pas à la
fabrication de hamburg heures je dirais
que ces récipients renfermait plutôt des
aliments comme des petits pois ou des
haricots et même des ingrédients comme
de la farine pour préparer les
pâtisseries ses échoppes étaient avant
tout des sortes d'épicerie
les denrées de base sont le pain les
olives et les fruits les classes les
plus aisées peuvent s'offrir de la
viande de porc ou du mouton la ville de
pompéi est à l'époque célèbre pour sa
spécialité de sauce de poisson appelé
garou c'est ici que l'on fabriquait ce
gardien que l'on mettait pour ainsi dire
à toutes les sauces dans la cuisine
romaine
presque tous les plats en comportait au
moins un mince filet on le fabriquait à
partir de maquereaux qu'ont laissé
fermenter des semaines durant dans des
jarres voici un exemple de ces
récipients si la fermentation dégageait
une odeur épouvantable la sauce
extraites par ce processus avait
curieusement perdu l'odeur du poisson
les gens étaient prêts à payer cher pour
ce condiment au goût particulièrement
délicat si je plonge à présent mama au
fond de cette jarre je peux encore
trouvé des restes de maquereaux
remontant à 80 ou bien 79 après
jésus-christ c'est tout à fait étonnant
regardez cette substance qui ressemble à
de la sciure ou bressieux ce chorus est
l'un des plus célèbres producteurs de
garos mme debons pays
son nom de famille apparaît même comme
une marque de fabrique
sur ces jarres de sauce vendus dans les
épiceries fines de toul en pire au hms
reçu ce chorus devient rapidement un
homme riche à sa mort ses descendants
vont perpétuer la tradition sur
plusieurs générations
à pompéi également le métier que
pratiquent un citoyen ainsi que le
domicile qu'il occupe révèle son niveau
de vie des fresques aux couleurs vives
représentant les scènes les plus
raffinés de la société romaine horn
l'intérieur des propriétés des classes
aisées
les seules sont habituellement garni de
mosaïques des milliers de fragments de
tuiles et de pierres assemblées
patiemment à la manière d'un immense
puzzle et représentants de magnifiques
scènes c'est dans ces intérieurs
richement décoré que l'on dort que l'on
mange et que l'on reçoit ses invités
[Musique]
nous sommes ici dans le triclinium ou
salle à manger
c'est la pièce la plus importante du
domicile et la plus décorée elle est le
lieu par excellence où l'on reçoit est
où le repas fait véritablement l'objet
d'un rituel triclinium parce qu il y a
trois divan alignés le long du mur sur
lesquels les invités repose appuyé sur
le coup de gauche en se servant la
nourriture à l'aide de leur main droite
le mythe hollywoodien nous présente le
dîner romain comme une orgie un banquet
monstrueux où des dizaines de
participants sont étendus lascivement
pratiquement les uns contre les autres
en fait je pense que la réalité était
bien plus modeste rarement plus de 9
personnes dîner en même temps dans cette
salle il y avait des esclaves qui
fourmillaient tout autour on voyait
passer là une ribambelle de plats on ne
mangeait pas de grands animaux mais une
suite de préparation qui ressemblaient
plus à des amuse gueule et que l'on
pouvait se servir facilement pour les
manger allongée
il est de coutume chez les romains de
sauter le petit déjeuner et le déjeuner
dans les familles aisées
le dîner s'éternise c'est pour ainsi
dire un événement gastronomique parfois
suivis d'un spectacle par exemple de
danseuses d'acrobates dans les foyers
plus cultivés on écoute volontiers de la
poésie pendant que le vin coule à flots
jusqu'au petit matin
tiens on pourrait appeler ce lieu la
chambre des machines de cette villa
c'est ici que les propriétaires
produisent eux-mêmes leurs vins on a
reconstitué l'un des deux grands
pressoir à vin qu'ils possédaient voici
les normes madriers orné d'une tête de
bélier qui foulaient le raisin pour
laisser s'écouler le jus en contrebas
celui ci était ensuite canaliser le long
du mur vers toute une série de cuves
comme celle ci ainsi que vers des
dizaines d'autres là-bas derrière
parfois les hommes s'esquive du foyer
pour se rendre dans l'une des nombreuses
maisons de passe de la ville la
prostitution est à l'époque un commerce
légal
les tenanciers sont également assujettis
à l'impôt les autorisant à exercer nous
voici à présent dans une ruelle retirer
de pompéi à l'intérieur du grand l'upa
nav
c'est un endroit incontournable pour les
touristes qui viennent ici ces scènes
pornographiques peintes sur les murs des
cris vos clients les spécialités de la
maison il y avait 6 5 chambres chacune
équipée d'un lit très rudimentaire
puisqu'il était en pierre un rideau
devaient pendre devant chaque porte
et l'on éclaire l intérieur à l'aide de
bougies mois qu'il n'imaginait que la
chose était peut-être plus réjouissante
sous l'antiquité qu'elle ne l'est à
présent
et voici un mur qui servait à recueillir
sous la forme de graffitis les
félicitations des clients
[Musique]
durant des siècles pompéi est une ville
florissante
jusqu'à ce jour fatidique du 24 août 79
après jésus-christ
le vésuve l'imposant volcan dominant la
ville entre en éruption
un nuage mobile de gaz de cendres et de
roches s'abat sur pompéi ainsi que sur
sa ville soeur air cool and um
sur le mont vésuve de grandes gerbes de
feu et de flammes jaillissaient de
plusieurs endroits leur éclat était
d'autant plus aveuglant qu'il faisait
nuit
pline le jeune
[Musique]
une pluie torrentielle de cendres
enseveli littéralement les maisons si
quelques rares personnes parmi les vingt
mille citoyens de pompéi et les 5000
vers culhane hommes parviennent à
s'enfuir à temps l'immense majorité
moeurs prises au piège sous 20 mètres de
retomber ou bien asphyxié par les fumées
toxiques
[Musique]
pompéi est une ville où le temps s'est
arrêté et dont les habitants sont restés
figés sur place
le désastre provoquent une onde de choc
jusqu'à rome
personne n'ose croire que la célèbre
ville de la baie de naples a été
anéantie quitus à leur empereur se rend
sur les lieux
il décide de lancer un programme d' aide
aux survivants
[Musique]
pompey en 79 après jésus-christ au
moment où l empire romain est à son
apogée
pompéi vite un grand moment de solitude
on voit d'un côté afflué dans sa région
le centre de l'italie
une profusion de richesses provenant des
quatre coins de lempire on a donc là une
sorte de boom économique et en même
temps pompéi doit véritablement se
relever de ses cendres
la destruction de pompéi symbolise la
fragilité et le caractère éphémère de l'
empire
si l'ancienne civilisation existe depuis
plus d'un siècle
des bouleversements s'annonce homme
demeure bien entendu la capitale
dirigeante mais les provinces commence à
exercer leur propre influence sur l'
empire
le vieil establishment romain se
retrouvent peu à peu confronté aux
nouvelles idées ainsi qu'aux 109 qu'elle
lui impose à la fin du 1er siècle après
jésus-christ le gouvernement n'est plus
un peuple réservé exclusivement aux
italiens l' empire est un employeur qui
ne fait plus de discrimination en 98
après jésus-christ le général trajan né
en espagne devient le premier empereur
mme anita lien ses compétences militaire
mais aussi politique en tant que
gouverneur de haute allemagne ont incité
l'ancien empereur nerva à le choisir
comme successeur à la fin du premier
siècle avant jésus-christ il est encore
beaucoup trop tôt pour qu'un provincial
venant d'aussi loin que l'espagne est
une chance de faire un tabac dans l'
empire romain
on a bien des exemples isolés d'hommes
devenu sénateur à rome métrage en a été
l'un des tout premiers à faire très fort
et ce après avoir été obligée de
surmonter tout un tas de préjugés à son
égard
trajan démontre rapidement ses aptitudes
à la souveraineté c'est un soldat
agressif s'intéressant de très près à la
politique étrangère et aux possibilités
d'étendre les limites de lempire métrage
en est aussi un philanthrope il lance un
programme d' aides sociales aux plus
démunis qui fonctionnera pendant plus de
200 ans
c'est lui qui décide de consentir aux
agriculteurs des prêts à faible taux
on l'a précis tellement pour ses
initiatives et la qualité de son
administration qu'on lui attribue le
titre de optimus prime cebs ou prince
parfait les citoyens romains éprouve
également du respect pour sa femme
pompéi à claudine à néant gaulle la
future france
cette première dame non italiennes
s'intéresse moins aux fastes de son
empire qu'à sa population
comme elle a l'air simple dans ses
vêtements et plein de bon sens avec
cette modeste suite qui l'accompagnent
comme elle paraît sans prétention
lorsqu'on la voit marcher dans les rues
pline le jeune al'inverse de sa femme
trajan est réputé pour ses dépenses
frivoles il a aussi une faiblesse pour
le vin et les jeunes garçons cependant
il se concentre essentiellement sur la
romanisation des territoires dont il
participe à la conquête notamment en y
développant larchitecture la technique
et la roma en retour les nouvelles
provinces exporte vers rome leurs
produits et nourriture exotique que l'on
trouve sur les marchés à commencer par
les immenses marché couvert d'autres
agents qui font vraisemblablement figure
de tout premiers centres commerciaux au
monde
je pense que le marché de trajan est
l'exemple le plus complexe et le plus
impressionnant d'architecturé romaine
qui nous étaient est transmis on ne
dispose d'aucune preuve archéologiques
ou littéraire qu'il s'agissait bien d'un
marché mais on n'a pas de mal à se
rendre compte qu'il est tout à fait
semblable dans sa structure à nos
centres commerciaux
on imagine bien les gens achetant leurs
provisions à un étage faisant du
shopping à un autre et comme ça jusqu'au
troisième étage avec des vêtements ou
peut-être des meubles de la bijouterie
c'est un lieu qui devait vibrer de
couleur de bruit et d'odeur très
exotique
un bel exemple de la nature cosmopolite
de rome
en développant le réseau routier romain
trajan facilitent l'importation et
l'exportation des marchandises au ivème
siècle après jésus-christ plus de 85
mille kilomètres de route traverse
lempire c'est un entrelacs complexe de
voies à grande circulation
partant en étoile depuis le centre
névralgique robe loin des commodités de
nos technologies les routes romaines
font néanmoins office de réseaux de
communication efficace entre la capitale
et ses provinces
l'armée romaine avait la réputation
méritée d'être techniquement très
compétente
c'est elle qui a véritablement construit
une grande partie des infrastructures de
l' empire pour lui doit en particulier
le grand réseau de route nationale qui
traverse tout le bassin méditerranéen et
qui avait été prévu initialement dans
l'intérêt de l'état
il s'agissait de pouvoir déplacer
facilement les troupes et les services
de renseignement du gouvernement ses
ancêtres de l'autoroute servent d'abord
effectivement acheminer l'armée
jusqu'aux confins des provinces où elle
s'en va combattre l'ennemi
elles deviennent peu à peu le moyen le
plus sûr de transporter ces marchandises
par chariot ou à dos de cheval c'est
aussi grâce à leur existence qu'un
premier service postal se met en place
le contrôle de rome sur ce très vaste
empire signifiait qu en retour la
capitale pouvait se permettre d'importer
à peu près tout ce qu'elle souhaitait
depuis le bout du monde et cette faculté
lui permettait de se maintenir comme
capitale du monde impérial c'est ainsi
qu'en sens après jésus-christ tous les
chemins mènent à rome
ces autoroutes de pierre permettent une
diffusion rapide de l'information de la
capitale vers le reste de l' empire
notamment en matière d'urbanisme et de
tendances architecturales l'aqueduc
figurent parmi les ouvrages les plus
convoités par la plupart des villes
romaines
tout comme rome les villes provinciales
ont besoin de s'approvisionner en eau de
manière continue on bâtit d'imposants
aqueduc pour acheminer l'eau des sources
environnantes
celle ci est canalisée vers un réseau de
tuyaux de plomb alimentant les fontaines
les établissements de bains ainsi que
les maisons de certaines familles aisées
duc reposer uniquement sur le principe
de gravité vous imaginez donc le savoir
faire technique incroyable dont ils
devaient faire preuve pour trouver
suffisamment de points
d'approvisionnement capable d'alimenter
ensemble une population donnée
la raison d'être des villes dépendent
entièrement de la proximité ou de
l'acheminement de l'eau tout reposait
sur le transport et l'eau les romains
développe également un système
sophistiqué de canalisations seuls les
riches possèdent à leur domicile des
latrines
la plupart des citoyens utilisent les
toilettes publiques
ce sont de longs bancs de pierre garni
de trous pour le moins ostentatoire ses
sanitaires d'extérieur deviennent des
lieux de réunion où l'on échange
volontiers les derniers potins tout en
faisant sa petite affaire
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que sous le règne de trajan
lempire commence à se transformer en
homme perd de plus en plus de sa
prédominance le transport plus rapide et
plus efficace permet un échange des
informations et des idées à travers l'
empire et contribue à décentraliser le
pouvoir
les provinces deviennent à leur tour des
centres de décision
[Musique]
si la ville de rome a toujours exercé sa
domination sur les provinces romaines
ces dernières influence à leur tour la
capitale impériale rome devient et
restera dès lors l'une des villes du
monde les plus riches culturellement
[Musique]
depuis les toutes premières années de la
république romaine tous les romains sont
obligés de servir la religion d'état
ceci signifie qu'ils doivent se rendre
régulièrement au près d'un temple public
y faire un sacrifice en l'honneur d'un
dieu particulier jupiter le roi des
dieux bacchus le dieu de la vigne et du
vin ou apollon le dieu du soleil
au coeur des principes de la religion
romaine figurent aussi le sacrifice à
l'esprit protecteur de l'empereur en
place ont effectué sous la forme d'un
don d'argent de nourriture ou bien en
tuant un animal mais avec les siècles
les citoyens se retrouvent peu à peu
confrontés à une multitude de coutume
religieuse affluent des diverses
provinces
d faut bien comprendre que les romains
ne vivent pas leur vie dans la tente de
notre vie le rôle principal des dieux
consiste à vous aider dans la
progression de votre existence
il ne s'agit pas de s'acheter une vie
après la mort mais plutôt de mener la
meilleure destinée possible ici bas en
sang après jésus-christ les négociants
les commerçants et les esclaves ont
commencé à déplacer avec eux d'autres
cultes et croyances mystiques à travers
l' empire dans sa grande majorité la
population romaine souscrit volontiers à
un certain nombre de ses croyances
exotiques l'empiré romain a créé les
axes permettant à ces religions de
circuler beaucoup plus facilement
qu'elle l'aurait fait jusque là par
exemple la déesse égyptienne
isis véritable pivot de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un culte mystique va se
voir adoré bien au-delà des limites de
l'italie jusqu'à londres où l'on
construit un temple à sa gloire dont les
soldats romains en particulier
deviennent de fervents adeptes de mithra
un dieu iranien incarnant la victoire du
bien sur le mal
son culte symbolisant la mort et la
renaissance plaît aux soldats confronté
par définition à leur propre mort au
champ de bataille partie des provinces
asiatiques
le culte s'étend au sud jusqu'en italie
et au nord jusqu'en grande-bretagne où
l'on trouve des temple dédié à mithra
ces cultes ne sont qu'une illustration
de l'immense diversité des religions
ainsi que de la tolérance régnant à
l'époque dans l'opinion
l'empiré romain se caractériser par une
assez grande tolérance religieuse on
acceptait la plupart de ces cultes temps
que leurs adeptes de rester par ailleurs
fidèles et heureux d'honorer la religion
officielle
c'était un moyen de prouver leur
dévotion à l'état roumain
trajan ferme le plus souvent les yeux
sur les développements de ces nouvelles
et nombreuses pratiques religieuses à
travers l' empire la population roumaine
ainsi que les empereurs qui lui
succéderont tient en haute estime son
sens de l'équité en tant que dirigeant
mais en 117 après jésus-christ trajan
meurt d'une attaque avec son épouse
pompe eia ils n'ont pas eu d'enfant rage
on n'a pas eu le temps non plus de
désigner son successeur
on raconte que pompey ya aurait falsifié
des papiers d'adoption afin de faire
d'adrien le plus jeune cousin de trajan
leur fils légitime et par conséquent
l'héritier du trône le couple l'a en
effet élevées après que celui ci ait
perdu son père à l'âge de 10 ans adrien
a grandi sous la tutelle de trajan pour
devenir un consul ainsi qu'un général
respecter adrien devient empereur à
l'âge de 42 ans né à rome est élevé en
espagne
c'est un homme impétueux qui a passé
l'essentiel de sa vie d'étudiants et de
jeunes soldats arpenter les provinces
romaines
il aime bousculer les traditions aussi
si le fait de porter des poils est perçu
dans la rome antique comme une attitude
barbare adrien devient le premier
empereur a affiché une barbe
[Musique]
il avait des cheveux frisés open et
portait une barbe complète et bien
taillé ses yeux était paraît-il clair et
perçant
il pouvait être une compagnie agréable
il avait un certain charme et se mêler
volontiers à ces humbles sujets qui
avaient dû le voir plus souvent que les
autres en preuve les histoires d'auguste
pour fêter son accession au trône adrien
commence par prendre une mesure
hautement symbolique
ils jettent dans un grand feu de joie
allumé au public tous les impôts et les
créances en se positionnant ainsi
ouvertement comme l'empereur du peuple
et à price théoriquement l'empereur
hadrien avait plutôt bonne presse en
particulier en occident où on le
percevait comme un empereur romain
pacifique et sensible s'intéressant plus
à la paix et à la prospérité des
provinces qu'à l'invasion de nouveaux
territoires
en nommant ses fonctionnaires parmi des
probations adria introduit des
compétences étrangères au sein d'un
establishment romain traditionnellement
corrompu et malsain il s'attache à
réformer le système juridique
[Musique]
dorénavant les citoyens ne peuvent plus
punir librement leurs esclaves en les
castrant ou en les jetant dans l'arène
des gladiateurs où ils finiront
déchiquetés par des animaux sauvages les
esclaves doivent désormais être jugé
devant une cour de justice
les pousses d'adrien se nomme sa bile
c'est la petite nièce de l'empereur
trajan mais leur mariage n'est pas un
mariage d'amour
adrien se plaint auprès de ses amis de
son humeur instable et difficile
de son côté sabine jure de ne jamais lui
donner d'enfant en annonçant
publiquement son utilisation de
contraceptifs à l'instar de nombreux
empereur l'ayant précédé adrien n'aura
pas d'enfants l'empereur doit
probablement la différence de son épouse
à son infidélité
on dit qu'il préfère les hommes aux
femmes une idylle amoureuse le lit
effectivement un jeune grec de 18 ans
antinoüs rencontré à l'occasion d'un
voyage en bithynie la future turquie le
terme homosexuels n'existait pas dans le
monde romain et le concept n'avait pas
la portée qu'il a aujourd'hui les
rapports sexuels avec d'autres hommes
étaient une pratique tout à fait
acceptable tant qu'on restait le
partenaire actif les romains fortunés
disposait d'ailleurs couramment parmi
leurs esclaves de jeunes hommes qu'ils
utilisaient pour leur plaisir sexuel
[Musique]
la sexualité est souvent une affaire de
domination tout dépend de qui se trouve
dessus dans un rapport homosexuel le
partenaire en position de soumission
perdre est en quelque sorte de son
statut si un citoyen voulait avoir des
rapports avec l'ancien esclave
ça ne pose aucun problème puisqu'il ne
faisait qu utiliser une partie de sa
propriété en revanche pas question pour
lui d'être le partenaire dominé au delà
de sa passion pour anti noces
adrien éprouve une soif insatiable de
parcourir le monde
il est déterminé à faire le tour de
lempire tout entier pour la première
fois la population habituée jusqu'ici
aux seuls noms de ces empereurs
s'apprête à découvrir aussi son visage
[Musique]
en 121 après jésus-christ l'empereur
hadrien débute la première de ses quatre
grandes tournées de l' empire romain un
empire dans les territoires s'étendent
sur plus de trois millions deux cent
mille kilomètres carrés englobant
quelques 4000 villes et 44 province
adrien est un politicien plein de bon
sens qui part à la rencontre des
gouverneurs des provinces d'asie mineure
de syrie et d'afrique du nord
au gré de son long périple ils goûtent
aux cuisine locale et s'imprègne des
différentes cultures
faisant partie du patrimoine national
pays
l'empereur était parfaitement au courant
que les gens avaient besoin de mettre un
visage sur son nom il n'y avait pas les
médias dont nous disposons maintenant
aucun équivalent à la télévision ni au
quotidien
adrien a donc consacré l'essentiel de
son long règne à arpenter une partie du
monde
en visitant ces provinces il avait
compris qu'il était capital pour
l'instabilité de lempire que tout le
monde le voit physiquement
[Musique]
ainsi adrien fait-il la promotion de son
image à travers l' empire
sur son chemin il distribue des pièces
frappées à son effigie presque toutes
les villes où il s'arrête lui rendent
hommage en lui consacrant un temple
de toutes les provinces parcouru c'est
la grèce qui l'a le plus impressionné
la beauté architecturale et artistique
d'athènes le frappe de stupeur son amour
pour la grèce devient si célèbre que les
romains le surnomme le grès six ans
[Musique]
adrien portait une barbe comme les
philosophes grecs ils s'habillent à la
manière des intellectuels grecque il
écrivait de la poésie grecque
il a pris un amant c'était presque une
caricature bien entendu à son retour à
rome
les vieux aristocrate qui s'étaient
opposés aussi à ce qu'il parte voyager
vers l'est ont déclaré voilà ce qui
arrive quand un empereur romain devient
grecque mais il est important de se
rappeler que les gens ordinaires n'ont
en aucune manière été choqués par sa
démarche
l'empiré romain était sexuellement
culturellement et religieusement
beaucoup moins intolérant que la plupart
des sociétés de notre xxième siècle
adrien a hâte de faire partager aux
italiens la culture grecque qui le
passionne dans
en 125 il débute la construction de son
palais impérial à tivoli à la sortie de
rome un domaine de 150 hectares parsemé
de temples de fontaine et de pièces
d'eau rafraîchissante tous ornés d'art
grec et de statuts pillés à athènes
[Musique]
adrien a également un faible pour l'art
dramatique c'est un mécène qui encourage
la construction de nombreux théâtres à
travers l' empire
aurora des l'idée d'un monte des
productions théâtrales est une invention
grecque au départ les romains étaient
étrangers à ce concept
et puis ils ont commencé à l'adopter eux
aussi les premiers théâtres se sont
ensuite peu à peu enrichie de décoration
en marbre
parfois même de larges colonnes
adrien exprime volontiers ses goûts
artistiques dans les édifices qu'il fait
élever en 118 après jésus-christ il
commandite la reconstruction de l'une
des merveilles éternelle de rome
le panthéon un temple dédié à l'ensemble
des dieux romains une percée aménagé
dans le dôme est appelée oculus agit à
la manière symbolique d'un puits de
lumière céleste pour de nombreux romains
c'est l'image des dieux les regardant du
plus haut des cieux
[Musique]
mais tout aussi passionné qu'il l'est
pour les arrêts larchitecture adrien
n'en est pas moins resté un guerrier
dans l'âme
l'empereur gère son empire comme une
forteresse en 122 il fait bâtir sa plus
grande réalisation
un mur de pierre 217km marquant la
limite de son territoire de grande
bretagne
il s'agit d'une barrière défensive
destinée à protéger l'empiré romain des
tribus barbares du nord
le mur d'hadrien tel qu'on le nomme
devient une ligne de démarcation
symbolique entre le monde dit civilisé
et le monde barbare
[Musique]
les vestiges de ce mur font aujourd'hui
office de monument commémoratif à la
gloire des bâtisseurs et des défenseurs
de lempire d'adrien après s'être ainsi
passer par la grande bretagne
adrien poursuit son périple à travers
son puissant empire de rome
[Musique]
en 130 après jésus-christ adrien entame
sa troisième tournée éclair des
provinces après sa traversée de l'asie
il s'embarque à l'ouest vers l'egypte où
il a étudié dans sa jeunesse la magie et
l'astrologie
adrien est un homme très superstitieux
que les cultes d'isis et d'osiris
fascine
[Musique]
à l'occasion de ce déplacement en egypte
et s'est entouré d'une suite imposante
son amant anti novus l'accompagnent
aussi entre ces rendez vous avec les
gouverneurs de province et autres
citoyens éminents il décide un jour de
se détendre en descendant le nil en
bateau mais pendant la croisière
antinoüs bise du conte de l'embarcation
et se noie l'entourage présents au
moment du drame d'irak adrien a réagi en
se mettant à sangloter comme une femme
son autre réaction consiste à déifier
littéralement son amant en baptisant de
son nom une ville au bord du nil
tout en continuant de pleurer la perte
dont in house adrien poursuit son voyage
à travers l' empire en 131 il entre en
jus baie peuplée essentiellement de
citoyens juifs mais l' empire qui a
toujours pratiqué une certaine tolérance
vis-à-vis des croyances religieuses
commencent à changer de point de vue
on se tue au sein de l' empire la
province de judée est évidemment la plus
embarrassante
c'est celle qui est la plus prédisposés
aux révoltes le fait qu'au coeur de
cette décidant c'est de cette résistance
se trouve le peuple juif est important
parce que cela souligne bien la
différence du judaïsme par rapport à
toute autre forme de religion à
l'intérieur de l'empiré romain le
judaïsme est une religion ethniques dont
les règles repose sur toute une série d
écrits et ceci en fait un groupe de
position beaucoup plus difficile à
renverser que n'importe quel autre
groupe religieux dans les autres
provinces de l' empire
à l'époque les croyances religieuses
circulant à travers l' empire se partage
entre de très nombreux dieux
parmi eux les dieux romains auquel les
citoyens doivent par force de loi faire
leurs dévotions
cependant les juifs ne croit et ne
peuvent croire qu'en un seul et unique
dieu leur refus de se plier à la
religion d'état engendre des tensions
entre l'empereur et les citoyens de
jérusalem capitale de la judée
le peuple juif se différenciait déjà
beaucoup des romains d'italie ne serait
ce que par ses coutumes alimentaires ces
détails vestimentaires et c'est un peu à
la manière dont de nombreux juifs
orthodoxes continue de se distinguer
aujourd'hui les conflits véritable entre
juifs et romain sont nées du fait que
les romains n'ont pas compris toute la
portée
la profondeur de la sensibilité
religieuse du peuple juif
le dédain de rome pour les pratiques
religieuses juives s'intensifient à
travers une série de violents
affrontements
en soixante dix les soldats romains
saccagent les rues de jérusalem
[Musique]
ils massacrent les citoyens et
incendient les temples sacrés l'écrivain
juif joseph relate ainsi leurs méthodes
il se précipitait à travers les rues
l'épée à la main et frappait sans
distinction tous ceux qui se trouvaient
sur leur passage
joseph
un petit nombre de juifs parvenu à
échapper à cette véritable tuerie
s'établit en communauté à massada qui
surplombe la mer morte depuis les
hauteurs du désert de palestine mais
cette ville fortifiée édifié par le roi
hérode dont 37 avant jésus-christ
n'échappe pas pour autant à la loi
romaine
de 67 à 73 après jésus-christ les juifs
parviennent à tenir à distance l'armée
romaine
mais en avril 73 à l'aide de catapulter
de bélier leur permettant de percer le
mur d'enceinte
les soldats donnent l'assaut à la
citadelle face à ce qu'elle considère
comme un destin inéluctable la colonie
juive préfère se suicider à la rentrée
dans le bastion les soldats romains
trouve 960 cadavres d'hommes de femmes
et d'enfants leurs martyrs restera un
symbole de la solidarité juive contre
l'impérialisme étrangers il siège de
massada a été pour les romains leur
opération la plus efficace qu il ne
magnifique démonstration publique
comme quoi nul ne doit tenir tête à
l'autorité d'europe massada va rester
ainsi un symbole de la puissance des
romains avec des échos jusque dans l'est
du bassin méditerranéen sur les risques
encourus
lorsqu'on s'avise de s'opposer aux
romains il y a bien entendu un débat
autour des juives de massada se sont ils
réellement suicider collectivement ou
bien ont-ils plutôt été massacrés tout
porte à croire qu'ils ont bien mis fin à
leurs jours
ceux ci changent considérablement le
sens de l'histoire
en conférant aux juifs une marque de
dignité dans leur résistance contre
l'envahisseur impérialiste et d'autre
part le siège de massada reste une
preuve de la puissance militaire
colossal des romains
si adrien c'est l'hostilité qui oppose
son gouvernement au peuple de vue d il
reste néanmoins déterminés à maintenir
jérusalem comme une ville romaine à son
entrée dans la ville sainte
ils annoncent la construction d'un
temple romain à la gloire du dieu
jupiter
les juifs apprennent avec consternation
que l'édifice se dressera à l'endroit
précis où s'est levé l'un de leurs
temples sacrés détruits par les soldats
romains
adrien continue de se comporter de
manière insultante en critiquant et en
dénonçant les rides culturel juif
[Musique]
adrien avait pourtant l'excellente
réputation d'être un pacificateur un
homme généralement respectueux des
coutumes des différents peuples fort mal
en pire
mais il avait beaucoup de mal à tolérer
certaines pratiques juive qu'il
considérait comme bizarre
le nouveau décret d'adrien est un
sacrilège un véritable outrage proférées
à l'égard du peuple juif en 132 en guise
de défi massif des milliers de juifs se
rassemblent pour manifester leur
opposition à l'état roumain à leur tête
figure si mon bar kokhba c'est un zélote
l'un des membres nationaliste juive très
actif à l'époque contre l'occupant
romain
pendant près de quatre ans les juifs
parviennent à repousser plusieurs les
jupes romaine mais après avoir massacré
plus de cinq cent mille juifs l'armée
romaine fini par prendre la ville de
jérusalem adrien ordonne qu'on lui
apporte le corps de bar kokhba
tesson dieu n'avait pas choisi de le
faire mourir qui donc aurait pu en venir
à bout
adrien
la révolte de bar kokhba est la plus
grande bataille militaire ayant eu lieu
sous le règne d'adrien l'armée à
restaurer l'autorité romaine dans la
province de vue d mais le conflit aura
laissé d'arbres souvenir des deux côtés
l'important à retenir de cet épisode une
épatant l'intérêt militaire que
politique de l'intervention romagne les
juifs étaient militairement insignifiant
aux yeux des romains ces derniers
voulaient simplement que chacun au moyen
orient comprennent qu'aucune résistance
de ce type ne serait tolérée
adrien rentrer à rome en 135 après avoir
visité 38 de ses 44 province
[Musique]
malade il passe la dernière année de sa
vie dans son palais de tivoli à sa mort
en 136 ont l'enterrent dans un monument
à rome aux côtés de son épouse sabine le
lieu de repos s'avère un convenable pour
un homme qui n'a jamais aimé sa femme et
qui a passé le plus clair de sa vie loin
d'elle et de la capitale
[Musique]
les noms périple d'adrien montre à quel
point bon nombre des provinces se sont
intégrés politiquement et économiquement
à l' empire romain au deuxième siècle
après jésus-christ le pouvoir passe des
mains de roms à celle des différentes
provinces
[Musique]
erwan 661 après jésus-christ l'empereur
marc aurèle déclare en tant qu'empereur
rome est ma patrie mais en tant qu'homme
je suis un citoyen du monde
il vient de résumer ce qu'est devenue la
citoyenneté romaine
on est bien loin du club élitiste qui
s'étendait autrefois sur le monde
méditerranéen désormais que l'on soit
modestes paysans vivant aux confins de
la grande bretagne ou bien un riche
aristocrate à l'abri de son palais
d'égypte un seul et même rôle nous unit
celui d'acteur du grand empire de rome
[Musique]